to have data on what's happening with
the infection spread you then right away
as quickly as you can trace that person
who have they met with who have they
been in close contact with over the past
14 days and you then contact those
people and say you may have been in
contact with dan dan tested positive you
should check your symptoms if you
develop any symptoms let me know right
away and we'll bring you in to take a
test that is Tracy the problem is it's
not rocket science to do it on an
individual basis the problem is the
scale that we have to do this at
yesterday we tested four thousand six
hundred eighty-one people who were
positive yesterday four thousand six
hundred and eighty-one people were
positive how do you now communicate with
four thousand six hundred and eighty-one
people trace back all the people they've
been in contact with over the past 14
days close contact and contact those
people that is an overwhelming scale to
an operation that has never existed
before we do tracing now but on a very
limited basis that's why this is so hard
tracing in and of itself one person it's
easy four thousand six hundred and
eighty one on one day today we'll have
another four thousand six hundred and
eighty one people so just think of the
scale of the operation last week we
announced that Michael Bloomberg would
lead the first ever testing tracing
isolation program figure out how many
people how to train them what technology
how do we do this and it's of a scale
never been done before and by the way
we need it tomorrow there is no time to
go get a university to do a study and a
blueprint and then put a plan together
we need it tomorrow because we're
literally doing it right now we're doing
the testing we're coming up to scale on
the testing you need the tracing to come
up the scale to meet what we're doing on
testing the estimate so far is you need
30 contact tracers for every 100,000
people who are in the affected area
statewide that would be about 6400 to
17,000 tracers depending on what happens
on the testing rate the more people test
positive the more tracers the less
people test positive the less tracers
you need so these things are all linked
right the better you do at reducing the
spread of the virus the fewer people
test positive and the fewer fewer people
you need to trace back but it will
require under any estimate a tracing
army to come up to scale very very
quickly and Mayor Bloomberg has put
together a great team who's gonna work
on this he has great talent in his
Bloomberg philanthropy Johns Hopkins
University working together with the New
York State Department of Health this is
that undertaking and it is massive and
that's why bringing in a person with a
talent of Mayor Bloomberg and the
experience of Mayor Bloomberg to do this
as essential where do you get the army
but we have Department of Health
employees all across the state counties
have them cities have them the state has
them we'll marshal those employees you
also have a lot of government employees
who are at home now getting paid but are
not working what government employees
who are now existing city state county
can we deploy to become tracers and then
training them etc after you go through
all of that if you don't have enough
you're gonna have to hire people and
then you have to train them right away
because nobody's done this before
they're gonna need help they're gonna
need technology they're gonna be
monitoring they're gonna have to be
tested before they can do this so it's a
massive undertaking and that's why Mayor
Bloomberg's involvement and his
generosity here is so important and we
want to offer a big thank you to Mayor
Mike Bloomberg who I believe may be
joining us by telephone or some
technological means there he is
how are you mayor my dear and good good
good to see you and I want to thank you
for all your good work leader this great
state through this crisis and to deliver
facts and data to the public and also a
sense of hope which really is important
I know your daily press conferences have
become must-see TV for a lot of people
and for your record what the record I
thought your advice to father's on what
to say about a daughter's boyfriend was
exactly right the other day anyways the
question and everybody's mind continues
to be how can we begin to loosen these
restrictions and begin reopening the
economy and one of the most important
steps to taking we have to take to
reopen the economy as safely as possible
is to create a system of contact tracing
as you just outlined when social
distancing is relaxed contract contact
tracing is our best hope for isolating
the virus when it appears and keeping it
isolated the governor has recognized
that and since Bloomberg philanthropies
has deep experience and expertise in
public health we're glad to support the
state in developing and implementing a
contact tracing program as Andrew said
the contract contact tracing is a way to
identify people who may have been
exposed to the virus but don't know it
and during doing that requires a lot of
well-trained people who are award
and managed effectively it is a very big
undertaking just because of the scale so
we've enlisted the best public health
school in the world at Johns Hopkins
University no offense but it's named the
Bloomberg School of Public Health which
our foundation work with sahn with on
public health and other issues and we've
also teamed up with the nonprofit
organizations vital strategies and
resolve to save lives they get the
contract
tracing program up and running a lot has
to happen first and hiring training
deploying and managing a small army of
New Yorkers as the governor said is
really the great challenge to help the
state recruit contact tracers we brought
in a staffing organization and we're
also teamed up with CUNY and SUNY both
of which will help identify potential
job applicants and I want to thank both
of them for their work in joining us to
help the state with training Johns
Hopkins has developed a training class
which can be taken remotely it will
cover all the basic information of
epidemics contact tracing and privacy
there's also a test at the end of the
training which you have to pass in order
to be hired so we're not going to put
out people there that don't know what
they're doing
we'll also put technology to use in
other ways vital strategies is
developing three new smartphone apps the
first will help contact tracers find
information and data quickly the second
will help the public provide information
to health departments and the third will
allow those in quarantine to access the
guidance and services they need
including the ability to report any
symptoms they may be experiencing vital
strategies is also working directly with
the state to develop protocols and
workflow materials for contract tracers
and methods that includes a
comprehensive playbook that will detail
the steps needed to do contact tracing
effectively and I want to make it clear
we will release that playbook publicly
so cities
the states around the country can use it
and so can nations around the world
that way the work we do here in New York
really can help fight the virus globally
we'll also bring in a group of outside
experts to conduct an evaluation of the
program so that other states and
countries can see what worked well and
identify areas they can improve on and
we'll learn as we go and make
adjustments and share what we've learned
sharing and spreading best practices is
something that Bloomberg philanthropies
works on with cities around the world in
about an hour I'll be getting on a call
with mayor's around the country which is
a call we hold every week it's been a
good way to share information and
strategies and I know all of the mayor's
are following the news of the contract
tracing program that we are starting
here and that other states have also
begun the process of starting now my
fourth before I turn it back over to the
governor
let me just echo something that he has
said repeatedly and that really is
important to remember as tough as these
times are we are New Yorkers and we've
been through a lot together
and we're going to get through this
together again so governor back to you
and thank you for everything you're
doing together we're gonna lick this and
get back to a normal life that we can
and we are so proud of the way the good
state are behaving thank you all thank
you thank you very much thank you very
much to Mayor Bloomberg this is such a
great asset for the state of New York
and all the people in it
this is a monumental undertaking you
know so many of these things that we
talked about just never existed before
testing of this magnitude contact
tracing of this magnitude it's never
existed so we have to design new systems
new approaches to do this and this
problem is bigger than any one of us but
it is not bigger than all of us and
using the expertise and the talent that
we have we get everyone to work together
here we will do this
and the mayor is exactly right New York
New York he says as a New Yorker in many
cases we've dealt with challenges first
we figure it out and then we work with
other places to actually learn from what
we've done I think this is going to be
one of those examples we want the best
system that we can have to get New York
open and to prep protect New Yorkers but
it will also be a laboratory to put
together the best system ever put
together so we can share that with other
governments and that's what Mayor
Bloomberg does so well he did as mayor
and he does it now through his
philanthropy so we'll develop the best
system here and then what we learn we
hope can benefit other people will also
be coordinating on this contact tracing
on a tri-state basis because many of the
people who come into New York live in
Connecticut live in New Jersey go back
and forth we don't want to get limited
by jurisdictions when you're doing this
contact tracing somebody terms turns out
you have a trace that takes you to a
person in New Jersey well we work in New
York we can't go to New Jersey
having that tri-state alliance makes
tremendous sense so I'm working with
governor Murphy and governor Lamont on
that I don't want to thank them very
much next problem
stone to stone of course the morass
right problem to problem across the
morass in this situation every day
there's a new problem that pops up okay
let's let's handle it next problem
in an emergency crisis situation what
happens is problems compound right
you're in the middle of a hurricane the
power lines go down now the power lines
go down
now the heat is off heat is off now
people are freezing in their homes we
didn't anticipate that I know but that's
what happens
one problem creates another problem it's
like a bad game of dominoes
and these problems compound each other
and the combination is often unforeseen
we have that now within New York City
subway system Daily News did a
front-page story which crystallized it
but it had been happening for weeks
and no one anticipated it but you have a
virus outbreak and this conditions on
the New York City subway system for a
variety of reasons have rapidly
deteriorated when you think about what
happened you can put it together in the
retrospective the kovat outbreak happens
New York City is a place of density
subways buses are a place of density MTA
employees who run that system care for
that system get sick call in sick as
they should they don't want to infect
other people the number of MTA employees
comes down number of NYPD New York
Police Department they get sick their
numbers come down you now have fewer MTA
workers you have fewer NYPD workers on
the trains and in the stations we have
now a greater need than ever to
disinfect the subways the buses and the
stations why because you're in the
middle of a pandemic this is a place of
density and you have thousands and
thousands of people going through these
subway stations these turnstiles and
these buses
trains and a.da vehicles because MTA
workers are sick and why PD officers are
sick you have fewer people to monitor
and maintain the system and this all
happens in the midst of a public health
emergency at the same time you have more
homeless people who now are on fewer
trains and you have fewer people to
outreach to the homeless people so now
you put all of this together and then at
the same time we need our essential
workers to go to work I said the other
day I had two great nightmares from day
one nightmare one you did everything you
did close down etc and you didn't stop
the rate of increase of the virus that
would have been a nightmare can you
imagine if it we did all of this and we
still saw that virus going up that would
have been a real problem
second nightmare the essential workers
say I'm not going to work
I'm not going the transit operators the
police the food delivery people say it's
too dangerous
I'm not going I'm staying home - you
don't have food you don't have power you
don't have transportation you don't have
electric now you see Society in a really
difficult situation so we need those
essential workers to go to work I am
pushing every day to get our essential
workers to go to work even though they
see a lot of their colleagues getting
ill you need those nurses you need those
doctors in very difficult circumstances
that's why I say they are the heroes of
today all the essential workers how do
our essential workers get to work they
need the public transit system it's true
in New York City's through all across
the state they need the buses they need
the trains they need the subways to get
to work we need them
they need the buses and they need the
subways and we are as a society me as a
spokesperson for the state I'm saying to
them every day I need you to do this I
know it's hard but I need you to do it
okay we need them to do it but what is
our obligation our obligation is to make
sure we're doing everything we can do to
keep them safe right that's my personal
obligation and it's the collective
obligation you want them to be there to
deliver the food
what's your obligation is to do
everything you're doing you can do to
make sure that they are safe while
they're doing it
the MTA understood where we were with
this global pandemic they stepped up
operations and we're cleaning trains and
buses every 72 hours which is an amazing
undertaking when you think about it to
clean all those buses and trains every
72 hours but we know the virus can live
for hours or even days on a surface
which means if somebody positive walks
onto a train this morning that virus can
be there tomorrow and the next day that
then changes the whole focus of the
problem you want to honor the essential
workers thank you thank you thank you
we'll fly airplanes we'll have public
demonstrations of gratitude yeah even
better than that is what you do and how
you act and let's make sure that we're
doing everything we can let's clean
disinfect those trucks those buses and
trains every 24 hours why because that's
the way we best protect the health of
our essential workers which makes sense
if you want the essential workers to
continue to come to work it makes sense
if you don't want the infection rate to
go up in your society it makes sense if
you don't want the essential workers
that get sick and again it is our
obligation
as human beings to reciprocate and make
sure we're doing everything we can now
to say disinfect every train every 24
hours is just a task that nobody has
ever imagined before okay I would wager
in the history of public transportation
in this nation you never had a challenge
of disinfecting every train every 24
hours this in fact how do you even
disinfect a train
you know we clean trains but how do you
disinfect this is a whole new process
these are new chemicals these are this
is new equipment for workers it's new
methods just think about it you have to
disinfect every place that a hand could
touch on a subway card every rail every
pole every door wherever a hand could
touch or coughing sneezing wherever
droplets could land right so you have to
disinfect that entire interior of the
car and then you have to disinfect the
stations the handrails everything that
people could be touching it is a massive
undertaking that we've never done before
but that is the right thing to do that
is as we said we've never done tracing
before we've never done disinfecting
train cars before but so what that's
what we have to do so figure out how to
do what you have to do and this is what
we have to do and I challenge the MTA to
come up with a plan they came up with a
plan they can disinfect all trains and
buses every night it can best be done by
stopping train service from 1:00 a.m. to
5:00 a.m. every night during the
pandemic so they can actually perform
this service
now remember the context that we're in
in this pandemic ridership is down 92% 1
to 5 are these slow hours 1 a.m. to 5
a.m. it's the lowest ridership estimate
is about 10,000 people run the system
override the system overall during that
period of time so the MTA will launch
what they call the essential connector
program they'll have buses dollar vans
and if necessary we'll provide for hire
vehicles to transport a person the uber
or the lift the vehicle via vehicles at
no cost to the essential worker during
those hours to provide transport so
people who need transportation during 1
a.m. and 5 a.m. can have it will have it
even to the extent of a for hire vehicle
paid for by the MTA remember 1 a.m. to 5
a.m. we don't have bars open we don't
have restaurants open so you don't have
a lot of traffic that you would normally
have you do have essential workers who
are using our trains and subways and
they will have transportation during
that period of time this is going to be
one of the most aggressive creative
challenging undertakings that the MTA
has done it's going to require the MTA
the state the city the NYPD to will work
together it's not that easy to stop
train service you have to close down
stations you have to make sure people
don't walk in then you have to figure
out how to clean all these trains and
all of these stations I've consulted
with the elected officials on the MTA's
recommendation
and we all agree to accept the plan on
the essential connector program the MTA
is undertaking something that people
would have said was virtually impossible
trains and buses will be disinfected
daily service will continue the MTA will
also disinfect the fleet on the MTA
metro-north and the Long Island Railroad
which is what goes out to Long Island
goes to the northern suburbs they can do
that without any disruption in service
because of the volume of ridership etc
so just think about it the entire public
transit system in downstate New York
will be disinfected every 24 hours this
is a joint MTA state city partnership we
are doing a lot of things here that
we've never done before and I am never
one to shy away from a challenge I don't
believe the government has that option
I'm never one to say well that's just
too much too hard too ambitious we can
do it I believe we can do it I believe
we can do anything I believe we can
build bridges I believe we can build
airports I believe we can defeat global
pandemics but this is as ambitious as
anything that we've ever undertaken and
it's going to require a lot of
extraordinary service and effort from
multiple agencies all working together
the MTA has stepped up by recommending
this plan the state will do whatever it
has to do a big part of this Falls to
the city and I've spoken to Mayor
DeBlasio it's going to require a lot of
assistance from the NYPD it's going to
require a lot of assistance from
different city agencies again closed
down every station close down the trains
we've never been here before and I
guarantee
another 10 things come up when we go to
do this that are also unanticipated
consequences so the mayor is really
stepping up to the plate here and is
doing something that no mayor has ever
attempted to do before we'll all do our
part we'll all work together but it's a
heck of an undertaking for the mayor and
I applaud him for his ambition here in
stepping up and taking this on you know
it's always easier to just say no it's
always easier to say we can't do it
because when you say we will try to do
it now you're changing things and
whenever you change there's opposition
every time so it's always easier just to
stay status quo it's always easier not
to risk to be not to try to raise the
bar because maybe you can't do it maybe
there will be problems so it's easier
just to say no it's easier to say this
is all we can do it's impossible that's
not what the mayor is doing here
the mayor is stepping up and he's
stepping up in a big way and I want to
applaud him for and I think we have the
mayor who is on the telephone or some
electronic means there he is
Mayor Bill DeBlasio welcome to Albany
doing something different doing
something necessary and being willing
together to go someplace we've never
been before you and I have talked about
this kind of idea a lot over the years
you know I think when we first met each
other the word disruption was considered
a bad thing in recent years it's taken
on a very positive connotation that when
we disrupt something that isn't working
or has been thought about a very narrow
way and we go someplace new and better
that's a positive and I think what we're
talking about today is exactly that and
I commend you and everyone the MTA and I
want to talk about why I think this plan
is so important in terms of our
essential workers our first responders
our health care heroes why I think it's
so important in terms of also addressing
homelessness in a new and powerful way
but I first want to say I want to
express my appreciation along with you
really appreciate back on one of your
previous topics the contact tracing
really appreciate that of my predecessor
Michael Bloomberg is stepping up in such
a big way for New York City in New York
State and the contact tracing the test
and trace approach is going to change
everything you and I are united in that
as well the aggressive approach in fact
governor York City right now is hiring a
thousand contact tracers with healthcare
background to supercharge this effort
and I think we are going to be able to
show this country a model that's going
to be extraordinarily effective in
beating back this disease so I look
forward to that partnership as well but
right here on the issue of the MTA we've
all been thrown the biggest curveball in
our lives with this pandemic but look at
the consistent heroism the health care
workers the first responders the grocery
store workers the pharmacists everyone
who came forward and governor I know you
feel it too it's probably the proudest
moment we've had as public servants in
this state in this city
watching the heroism of these New
Yorkers who have stepped up now we owe
it to them to understand their lives and
the notion that they have a daily
routine where they go into battle they
go toward the danger to go where the
infection is which so many people
couldn't even imagine but that's what
these heroes are doing we owe it to them
to support them every way possible you
and I have talked many times about the
TPEs and the basic protections but we
also owe it to them to be safe on the
way to work on the way back home to
their families so I think what we're
doing here in part
ship is exactly the right thing to say
we're going to find a way to make our
subway system cleaner than it's probably
ever been in his history honestly and
address this crisis in a whole new way I
agree with that and I commend you for
and ad took some disruption just say
we're gonna do something there in this
pandemic we've never done before but it
makes sense when it comes to protecting
our heroes the second point
homelessness look another issue you and
I got on that date well we know it's
been in many ways an intractable issue
because there wasn't always an impulse
to disrupt and here is an example I'm
saying look we now have found new ways
to get Street homeless people off the
street but I want to commend
Commissioner Dermot Shea and everyone
the NYPD who's really focused on how to
help the homeless Commissioner Steve
banks everyone at homeless services and
social services and all those also those
heroic outreach workers governor you
know about this work we'll go out there
day after day to engage almost people on
the streets in the subway get their
trust and get them to come in to shelter
and ultimately to permanent housing this
work has always been in some ways
stymied by the reality of a homeless
person who is struggling with everything
they're dealing with a mental health
challenge a substance abuse challenge
riding the subway all night long we're
New Yorkers we know about this reality
and it's been putting a stark light by
this crisis like so many other
challenges and disparities have well
it's an unacceptable reality and this
new plan will disrupt that unacceptable
reality and allow us to actually get
help to people more effectively because
if you're not going back and forth all
night on a train then you actually are
coming above ground where outreach
workers are there to help you where NYPD
officers training to the homeless
outreach are there to support homeless
people and get them to a better
situation a governor you know for
decades in this city somehow a homeless
encampments were actually tolerated
people thought oh it's the kind of thing
what could we do about that I'm proud to
say in the last few years
homeless services NYPD non
profit organizations we got together and
we said we're not allowing that anymore
we shut him down and we found it
actually helped us to get the homeless
to the help they need this is another
example of that so I want to let you
know that as we all talked about this
idea and I commend you your team in
Albany and obviously a team at the MTA
pad for Sarah Feinberg it's been a very
productive conversation these last few
days and what I think we've come to get
there yeah we're gonna do something
unprecedented well do something because
of emergency but we're also gonna do
something that's gonna protect people
and offer a new way to get people help
we never got enough and so governor
thank you I think this is a partnership
you're right it's not gonna be easy
no one said it was gonna be easy but you
have my full commitment the commitment
commitment the NYPD and all of our
agencies we're gonna make this work
together and we're gonna be able to look
back and say we did something that
actually changed people's lives for the
better and as long as it takes will
understand when you and get this done
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much mayor de Blasio mayor made a
lot of good points you're right bill no
but nobody ever said it was going to be
easy but nobody ever said it was going
to be this hard either and I think the
mayor's point is very well taken look
we're doing things all of course the
board here that had never been done
before and I think there are lessons to
learn and lessons we'll take with us
telemedicine I think as a lesson we'll
take with us tell education remote
learning it's a lesson we'll take with
us a new Public Health System is a
lesson that will take with us and I
think we're going to improve and learn
from this experience with the New York
City Transit System because the truth is
it wasn't working well
or as well as it should before we did
have a problem with the homeless and
Bill is Right mayor de Blasio was right
I've worked on it all my life
out reaching to homeless people is very
very hard and getting them to come in to
a place that actually provides services
is very very hard
so this can actually energize the
connections with outreach workers in the
homeless population and we've we've
never had to disinfect trains like this
or buses like this and they will be
cleaner than ever before so global
pandemic but you live you learn you move
on and most importantly you meet the
challenge you meet the challenge and
this is a daunting challenge and the
mayor is stepping into it with eyes wide
open and it takes guts and it takes
courage and there'll be bumps along the
way I guarantee you but that's where we
are and that's why we get the big bucks
but I also want to be able to say today
to the essential workers we thank you
not just with words but with our actions
and I want you to know we're doing
everything we can to keep you and your
family safe and that's what it means to
say thank you act with gratitude so just
use the words act with gratitude they're
on those trains they deserve to be kept
safe they deserve to have a clean safe
ride to and from work and they're going
to have it and we're going to move
heaven and earth to make sure that
happens so in a challenge what do we do
we come together and we rise to the
occasion never did it before
I know so we'll do it now and we'll
figure out how to do it and we've
overcome every obstacle that we've been
thrown we have the beast on the retreat
we're making ground every day we just
have to keep it up
and we will because we are New York
tough we are smart we are disciplined we
are unified and we are loving questions
in terms of the subways shutdown will
that be
to the on pause order or what are the
exact parameters for that know that you
do with the unopposed order it goes into
effect when is the effective date and on
the on pause order when do we expect a
decision on that these of these schools
and other other four I said by the end
of the weeks when you were asked earlier
this week I said by the end of the week
like nothing changed like way tomorrow
that's the end of the week unless you
have a different calendar at the New
York Times okay what do you see response
to criticism that Seattle was quick to
respond to the coronavirus while you and
Mayor DeBlasio know we're not as quick
what's your response to that criticism
it's factually wrong no state moved
faster at the time from the first case
to total shutdown if you count days no
state moved faster from the first case
to total closed on March 1st to March
19th and no state at that time moved
faster so period the emphasis at the
beginning of this was on the west coast
they did the China travel ban they
stopped the international flights that
were coming in to the west coast what
they didn't do was shut down the
international flights coming to the East
Coast where did the flights from Europe
come New York and Newark where are you
seeing the problems with the cases New
York City in northern New Jersey we now
know based on reporting from the New
York Times in the last several days
there were at least 10,000 600 cases in
New York City before we even knew of our
first positive case so while the federal
government focused on the west coast and
closed down travel that was coming in to
the west coast and they had their first
cases in January and California did
they're shut down on March 19th
we did not they didn't close down travel
to Europe until I think it was March
16th we now know there were at least
10,000 600 cases in New York I'm betting
that number is higher by the time we got
our first positive case confirmation on
March 1st and as the governor said we
shut down fully by March 20th and
between March 1st and March 20th we shut
down schools colleges casinos movie
theaters bars and
we did it on a tri-state basis and with
literally zero guidance from the federal
government also just look I'm not in big
in pointing fingers or doing Monday
morning quarterbacking especially when
you're in the middle you're in the
middle of the game but the times you go
back and look they didn't write an
editorial saying we should close down
until after I close down write the
sources they quote saying well maybe we
should have closed down earlier after
that said there's no evidence that says
closed down of schools for example makes
a difference so you know if you don't
have to be consistent and it's easy to
raise a point the lot depending on who
you talk to people would say you get a
range but people would say you had cases
coming here from Europe which nobody
knew we had something like 2 million
people coming from Europe because the
virus went from China to Europe and then
came here from Europe nobody saw that
happening otherwise you would have done
a Europe travel ban when you did a China
travel ban and just nobody saw that
coming
and if Yuri what rewind the tape then I
would go back to November December when
you knew there was a virus and who were
the international watchdogs and who were
the international public health
operations where is the CDC in the NIH
and all those guys back in November
December January
where was the New York Times editorial
board you know everybody missed it
governor's don't do global pandemics
that's not in my job description where I
signed a bill depends on what the bill
says and I would need to see the bill
and then make the decisions rent is due
tomorrow people are you know still not
receiving their unemployment benefits
we're going over this every single day
we keep hearing the same thing every day
but these people they're doing their
part they're staying home
what kind of rental assistance can the
state provide and what sort of steps can
the the Department of Labor do to kind
of help these people and move these
process this process along faster yeah
we're doing everything we can to move
the unemployment checks faster every
state is dealing with this if you look
at our state's processing of cheques
it's actually way ahead of what other
states are doing most other states also
we're still dealing with the last
legislation that was just passed by the
federal government that had a new
program that had had to be implemented
but on housing no one can be evicted for
non-payment of rent period and the story
you cannot be evicted for non-payment of
rent we did that by an executive order
that executive order has weeks left to
run so I'm not saying people shouldn't
pay the rent you should pay the rent if
you can pay the rent but if you can't
pay the rent you're not going to be
evicted when we get to the end of that
period then we'll have to figure out
what to do because you don't want to
have a situation where nobody pays rent
and then landlords start walking away
from buildings either right that would
make a bad situation worse now I know
the state is broke but states like
Montana for example they provided
they're now completely different sort of
scenario but they did provide some of
the residents with rental is
is that something the state can do yeah
if I were the state of Montana I would
do that too we're not we have a thirteen
billion dollar deficit from Fire
Department police department transit
workers toxic shock let me refer that to
dr. Zucker so what the virus seems to
affect different parts of the body we
know it affects the lungs we also know
it affects the lining of the blood
vessels what we have been seeing is that
there are some children who have and may
have an inflammation of those blood
vessels and they're developing a toxic
shock like syndrome I've spoken to the
medical directors of our major medical
centers there are a handful of kids that
they've noticed it's it's rare it's been
reported overseas I've spoken to the
experts across the country about this as
well took the subway a few days before
or went to the supermarket how do you
alert and can you will learn all the
people that were in either of those you
do the best you can they call you up now
remember it's not you can theoretically
be infected if the person didn't have a
mask if you inhale droplets etc but what
they do is they interview you they come
up with the people who you believe you
were in close contact with family
members etc people you went to dinner
with etc and then they go down that list
and that's why this task becomes so big
so fast right 4,600 people yesterday
test positive you're one of those people
I called you up just ever D let's go
over the past two weeks of your life
pull out your journal and your phone and
your calendar who did you see who were
your dinner with
who did you embrace do you have a
significant other and you then would
come up with a list of 20 people and
then you have to call all those 20
people and say by the way you may have
been infected and let me know if there's
any sip symptoms call me back here's my
text go to this website go to this app
I'm it's a massive exponential explosion
of numbers of people and you do the best
you can because every positive you find
you then go to isolate what is isolate
me and that's also another tree isolate
means you have to be isolated so you
don't infect anyone else where do you
live well I live in a house and I have
four other roommates and I'm afraid I'm
going to infect my roommates that's a
problem we'll find a hotel that you can
stay at where you'll be isolated so you
don't infect your roommates right or you
can stay at home my brother's case lock
them in the basement
and throw away the key but you then have
to have a house where you can be
isolated that way so you then need
isolation facilities for those people
who needed an isolation facility so you
have to identify hotels etc with a
number of rooms for those isolation
people that's why none of the steps is
hard it's the volume and the scale of
all of these steps taken together
getting the testing up to 40,000 tests
per day 40,000 tests per day generate
5,000 positives each one of those
positives has to go through tracing
every one of those positives that means
isolation has to be placed in an
isolated
I mean it just explodes it's everyone in
this room but I also went to Target
yesterday and came into contact with
whoever was that target you can't if you
can't they have some really high-tech
apps where they trace your cell phone to
see what other cell phone hits were near
yours that raises a lot of questions
also but if it was just I don't know
that we've gone to this level of detail
but my instinct is if it's just you were
in target and you don't know any names
of who you came in contact with I don't
know what you would do with that we have
some upstate I can get you the exact and
names and numbers of those places child
care continues to be a concern for
essential workers and of course will be
for workers who come back during phase
one this is an issue all across the
state in New York and upstate parents
are asking us about summer camps and I
know Republican congresswoman Elise
Stefanik and some other local leaders in
the Capitol region have drafted a letter
to your office asking for clarity
because I guess some of these camps open
at the end of May and these are vital
for some parents who will be working
have you made any decisions on summer
camps yeah do them second would you say
to Representative Elise Stefanik and all
our great Washington representatives we
could provide rental assistance for
people who can't pay rent we could
provide childcare for essential workers
we are now you know what it takes money
funding money they passed the bill you
know how much it gave New York State to
do any of the things we're talking about
zero zilch nada so when one of them says
I have a great idea
why don't we do this for every person
would suggest maybe you say to them oh
are you providing any funding to do that
because the state has a thirteen billion
dollar deficit they provided us nothing
nothing for police nothing for
firefighters nothing for schools nothing
for teachers nothing for rental
assistance nothing for the massive
governmental operation we have to put
together with all of these things
nothing so yeah you can do a lot of good
things but you need funding do you know
about summer cares as we face in decide
on reopening in certain parts of the
state what we're looking at is looking
at whether or not daycare what kinds of
childcare be provided and whether cancer
will be able to open for the purpose of
providing child care to the extent that
we're putting people back to work in a
limited basis but those are those are
part of those discussions right now
let's do we know another two who hasn't
asked the questions
wondering what the State Health
Department is doing to investigate that
or therefore their complaints prior to
yesterday the we are investigating that
funeral home there were no complaints
about that funeral funeral home to the
Department of Health in the past and we
have they should guidance out to all the
funeral homes that we will not tolerate
any of that kind of behavior
and also why were these bodies kept in
unrefrigerated
[Music]
we have reviewed it we do review it for
every region again it's just the numbers
you look at the state we have different
numbers across the state I know the
hospitals want to get back to elective
surgery many of them are under real
financial pressure and elective surgery
is one of the places where they make
money frankly in those parts of the
state where we know we have hospital
capacity then we've opened them up to
elective surgery we do have a buffer on
the capacity because if you go up to 95%
capacity in a hospital and you have a
kovat outbreak then what happens then
you're right back to where we started
which is scrambling all across the state
to try to find the bed to try to find
PPE so we have a built-in buffer you can
go up to 70% but you have to leave 30%
for a buffer in case that co vid number
spikes and remember how do you track the
kovat number we're doing testing more
than ever before but this is an
imprecise science we're doing antibody
testing but the antibody testing
actually operates on a two-week lag the
antibody testing is telling you who got
infected two weeks ago right and now has
the anti
is to have the antibodies yet to recover
from the virus so like my brother now
has the antibodies yeah but it was two
weeks so let's not make the same mistake
or not let's learn the last lesson of
what we went through
you need a buffer on the hospital system
and that's why we say 70 to 30 different
regions in the state are not out of the
woods yet
and it's don't get cocky right that's a
lesson in life don't get cocky don't get
arrogant you still see a high number in
many places and where the number is
higher we don't want to relax the
elective surgery because we may need
those beds for people who are gasping
for air
yeah well worst-case scenario you go to
Saratoga County if you really have to go
now but we don't want to be in a
situation where we have a covert
outbreak and we have no hospital beds
that would be the worst thank you guys
[Music]